good morning kick it's Tuesday so listen
I've got some big news but first I just
took the most magnificent bath like I
don't want to be hyperbolic but I
consider myself something of an expert
in bands I've taken a bath most days of
my life and this is the greatest soap I
have ever encountered all right hold on
I gotta take the kids to school but
write the news so Hank when you got
cancer I became The Reluctant and
temporary CEO of dftba.com an e-commerce
company that connects fans to creators
like the McIlroy brothers or Kurtz
Gazette and also makes the awesome socks
and coffee clubs and Sun Basin soap the
clubs then donate 100 of their profit to
charity and so far we've raised over
five million dollars to support better
child and maternal Health in Sierra
Leone it's just the best and the people
who work there are amazing now did I
want to become the CEO of this company
and attend a lot of meetings not
necessarily but I I am aware Hank just
to State the obvious that I wasn't the
protagonist of the story so right when
we first started making Sun Basin soap
we had a problem like how do you
communicate what a soap smells and feels
like when you're in Internet company
like nobody's invented smell-o-vision
and we do have a sample pack that lets
you sample each of the five soaps but
ultimately we wanted to communicate not
just how the soap smells but but how it
feels and that's notoriously difficult
because we're headed toward the places
that language can't touch enter dftba's
Zoe Ryder who wrote the most brilliant
descriptions of these soaps Hank she
wrote for instance that Enigma our
unscented bar feels like the liminal
heir of a spring evening potential in
every breath and it's true for
Trailblazer our Tangerine Sage bar she
wrote that it's an unseen curve in a
Winding Trail and the thrill to discover
what's beyond that is such a better
description of this bar of soap than
anything representational when I say we
work with an amazing group of people
Hank that's the kind of stuff I'm
talking about like this is forager or
foresty bar for people who want some
like hardcore exfoliation Zoe called it
a sprout peeking through leaves and
winter debris pale green life beginning
again when you nailed description of a
soap that way is it copywriting or is it
poetry I think the answer is yes so Hank
the announcement that I'm making is that
in one week I will no longer be the CEO
of dftba.com I wasn't very good at the
job and I am thrilled to be demoted back
to my natural role as unpaid social
media intern making third tier memes
about our truly exceptional coffee but I
have to say I will nonetheless miss the
job because it's such a joy to be with
people who care about their work and
together are really making something
special so here in my last week I want
to thank everybody in the warehouse who
taught me how to pack and ship everybody
at customer service who taught me how to
make our customer experiences as
exceptional as our products and
everybody in the projects and products
team who help me understand how you make
stuff responsibly and thoughtfully but
anyways my last act as CEO I want to
encourage you to buy Sun Basin soap
which is truly the best soap in addition
to forager Enigma and Trailblazer we
have Navigator this one is more lightly
exfoliating has a great fresh Japanese
peppermint sent but why listen to me
when you could listen to Zoe it's Open
Fields with Horizons obscured by humid
Haze and also we have Daydreamer which
Zoe describes as the clink of settling
ice in a glass of lemonade oh and one
more thing Hank you are not going to be
the CEO of dftba.com Hank and I will
remain deeply involved at dftba but when
Hank got sick we were actually several
months into the process of trying to
find the right person to lead the
company and we've found her her name is
LJ jukonski she is a brilliant leader
who is passionate about dftba's Mission
she has Decades of experience doing this
stuff and really wants to come to dftba
because of the difference that we're
trying to make in the world so for the
last time as dftba's CEO buy our soap
and also our coffee and our socks 100 of
the profit goes to charity Hank I did it
I speed ran CEO thank you for trusting
me with it I'll see you on Friday